[SPEAKER_01]: Fourth of Wealsun, in the early afternoon in the palace of Lord Jameis, Jude and Paul Rivero discuss their next steps.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: Where do you see yourself?
[SPEAKER_02]: You've met Gouge.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you continue on your process...
[SPEAKER_02]: Solely speaking in your skill set, you're going to be heading towards that direction.
[SPEAKER_02]: Don't get me wrong, I like Gouge and I've traveled with Gouge and I've worked with Gouge for a long time.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I'll continue to work with him.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I mean, he's just a killer.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is that what you see for yourself or what you want for yourself?
[SPEAKER_00]: Not exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I'd also like to learn to be a little bit of a mage also.
[SPEAKER_02]: What is it about being a mage that you think that you know?
[SPEAKER_00]: From my grasp, understanding it has to do with... What are you talking about?
[SPEAKER_00]: Just reading the scroll?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm curious.
[SPEAKER_02]: Every new initiate to the arcane school usually comes with a bunch of bullshit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, to be honest.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm asking you what your brand of bullshit is.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to know how it works, but I also want to be able to compete with others that have magical influence.
[SPEAKER_02]: Power.
[SPEAKER_02]: I like that, magical influence.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you want power.
[SPEAKER_02]: What do you want power for?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, the last time when we went up against those
[SPEAKER_00]: Rogue, Mage, Wizard, Fox or whatever, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Did they totally?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, totally.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, they pissed me off too.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I wasn't exactly as useful as I would have liked.
[SPEAKER_00]: There was nothing I could to combat their spells.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can work with that.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you felt ineffective?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's a limit to cutting throats?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, don't get me wrong, Gage's gouge is awesome in a pinch, but when you're facing
[SPEAKER_02]: Somebody that knows how to use arcane energies, it's going to be different.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you have any kind of natural inclination towards it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Any talent, I guess?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I think I do.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not exactly sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I show him my little lizard thing that I made.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, right.
[SPEAKER_02]: You had the, what do you call it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Homunculus.
[SPEAKER_02]: Homunculus.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pulls up onto Paul Ribeiro's hedge.
[SPEAKER_02]: He said he created this.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which actually is a very interesting tweet.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've never created a homunculus myself.
[SPEAKER_02]: What do I know about the... Do I know anything about the creation of a homunculus?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh my god, I... You are not a... You're not a aficionado in this knowledge, but you know that this was actually a popular magical
[SPEAKER_01]: Endeavor in Keoland for hundreds of years.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, there were people that made quite a bit of money creating these little creatures for the entertainment of kings.
[SPEAKER_02]: As an arcane specialist myself, you know, as a mage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Archivist.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do I know what goes into the making of a homunculus?
[SPEAKER_02]: Aside from just the popularity.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well... Like, is it a blood magic?
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it a...
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, so, truthfully, what you've known about is, a lot of it is, um, uh, scam.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, I think it's like a bullshit illusion.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, so, even worse than that, a lot of it has basically been not even
[SPEAKER_01]: Something that even an accomplished illusionist would think could be ridiculous.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's been popularized so much.
[SPEAKER_01]: Good illusionists can actually do much better than that.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is real.
[SPEAKER_01]: What Paul Rivero did is actually something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Most of the people that were doing the homunculi stuff
[SPEAKER_01]: They were like jarred frogs, pickled frogs, stuff like that, that had their faces smiling or whatever.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is not bullshit.
[SPEAKER_01]: So tell me how you did that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Don't hold back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because if it sounds like bullshit, I'm going to think that...
[SPEAKER_00]: I have the papers actually on how I made it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, you have the books.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you don't remember literally, you can tell him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I give him the papers, I think.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to produce the tome that was written by Grayson?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or do you just want to tell me?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'll just tell you how I did it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm pretty sure I just pricked my finger with blood and I had clay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to tell him where you got the formula?
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't even remember where I got it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I would ask...
[SPEAKER_02]: So if I know that it's real... Oh, uh... No, just... Oh, just plug them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorry, sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So remember you found the manual on how to make a homunculi that Grayson had been creating.
[SPEAKER_01]: You found a couple of sample homunculi and you made your own using that tome as the instruction.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have that book.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Would I not want to show him?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to give Jude all your secrets?
[SPEAKER_01]: Not really.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then just say, I had a tone that told me him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or, you know, I mean, he doesn't know about Grayson yet, or your mother.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the question is, do you want to give him all that information?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Steve?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah?
[SPEAKER_02]: You're good.
[SPEAKER_02]: I heard Steve.
[SPEAKER_02]: Didn't hear anything else for the S part.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have a tome that told me how to do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Who gave you the tome?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, how do you know how to read?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a magical tome, correct?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it's a magical tome.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you knew how to read it, or did somebody instruct you?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I'm trying to determine if I'm going to teach you...
[SPEAKER_00]: I know how to read it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, we have a library here that has all of the ways how to...
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, this shit's not just kept in a library.
[SPEAKER_02]: I understand that maybe because of your connections with Lord Jameis that you have access to special shit, but reading arcane
[SPEAKER_02]: Spells is more than just what's in, like, the library.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, when you spend 20 years locked up in a palace, not really able to do much, your mind tends to wander.
[SPEAKER_02]: You were locked up?
[SPEAKER_00]: Not exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Figure of speech, but you get the idea.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why would you be locked up?
[SPEAKER_00]: I didn't say I was locked up.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, that's okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Even if it was just a figure of speech, why would you be kept on palace grounds?
[SPEAKER_02]: Even if you had Veronica in palace grounds?
[SPEAKER_02]: I understand you have connections, I'm just not entirely sure why you would be coddled.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because I'm royalty?
[SPEAKER_02]: How?
[SPEAKER_02]: I thought you were connected to Lord Jameis, which is fine, but he's not royalty.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's the nephew of Lord Jameis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: A Prince Jameis.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that's already been made aware to me?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I was gonna say.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was gonna say.
[SPEAKER_00]: I thought this was...
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, but why would they keep you locked up?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, you got the face mask thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've never seen you without it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you hideous?
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you deformed?
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you have a cleft palate?
[SPEAKER_02]: Were you burned?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: So why would they keep you locked up?
[SPEAKER_00]: Why do you care to know?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because I'm about to be your instructor in magical arts, and if you're mentally fucked up or twisted in the head... No, I'm not mentally fucked up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I'm not the one that blew the other guy's head off and threw him down the cliff.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, that was you.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was necessary.
[SPEAKER_00]: Necessary?
[SPEAKER_02]: You're not gonna tell me that killing a silly human, especially a Toli human, it's not gonna bother me.
[SPEAKER_02]: What I'm saying is you just said that you were locked up even if you weren't.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's say that you were restrained to palace grounds.
[SPEAKER_02]: You said for 20 years.
[SPEAKER_02]: That to me sounds pretty extreme.
[SPEAKER_00]: What I'm saying is I've lived here my entire life.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you don't know shit about the world other than through books?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: You've read a lot of books then?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I go through a list of shit that he might have read.
[SPEAKER_02]: Such as?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, you know, the classics.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll start with the easy classics.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of magic or history?
[SPEAKER_02]: Just basic education.
[SPEAKER_02]: Basic education.
[SPEAKER_02]: History, philosophy, that kind of stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, you list off several things that are human, not elderly.
[SPEAKER_02]: Human, yeah, of course, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he's read most of them.
[SPEAKER_01]: And actually, you figure out that he is very well read.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And...
[SPEAKER_02]: This is how I'm trying to gauge your intelligence.
[SPEAKER_01]: The deal is, is that, um...
[SPEAKER_01]: Go in and check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is it secret?
[SPEAKER_02]: You need to cast a spell.
[SPEAKER_02]: Secret.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, it's a drawer.
[SPEAKER_00]: D&D drawer.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sixteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: He tells you, you realize that his mother had been focusing his studies better than most royal scholars would do.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So she had a paradigm of study for him.
[SPEAKER_01]: My mom maybe read that.
[SPEAKER_01]: My mom talked to me about that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Obviously his mother was directly involved in this education.
[SPEAKER_01]: And very intelligent.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, probably better than most
[SPEAKER_01]: You're actually pretty impressed by the instructions she gave him.
[SPEAKER_01]: And she died when he was young, but by 10 she had given him an appetite for knowledge and a level of education that few who entered many of the academies in Keoland or even in
[SPEAKER_01]: The Arcane Order.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he's got a solid foundation.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: More so.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you want to be affected?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can you tell me what your hang-ups are?
[SPEAKER_00]: My hang-ups?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you know, like, I don't know, you want to blow away all the bullies that ever, like, fucked with you when you were little.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do I...?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like that's a hang-up.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, you got it in, you got a vengeance trip.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't really care.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you have any other hang-up?
[SPEAKER_02]: That's what I'm saying.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like hang-ups.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hang-ups are things that you're stuck on from like maybe your youth prior to learning magic.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to prove myself.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: My worth.
[SPEAKER_00]: Earn my keep.
[SPEAKER_02]: You want to be valuable.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can certainly understand being valuable.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I asked him if he had any hang-ups.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he asked me what I meant by hang-ups.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I'm like, you know, do you want to go kill everybody that ever bullied you?
[SPEAKER_02]: And he said- I don't care.
[SPEAKER_02]: He said no, he doesn't care.
[SPEAKER_02]: He said he wants to be, what was the word you used?
[SPEAKER_00]: Valuable.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or I want to prove myself.
[SPEAKER_02]: He said prove yourself and I said valuable.
[SPEAKER_02]: So give me one example and I'll train you of
[SPEAKER_02]: How that desire to be valuable can get you into deep shit?
[SPEAKER_00]: My family has had a hard time seeing me as any use to principalities.
[SPEAKER_02]: That is along those lines, and I understand.
[SPEAKER_02]: You want to prove yourself.
[SPEAKER_02]: You said prove yourself.
[SPEAKER_02]: I said be valuable, or be deemed to be of value.
[SPEAKER_02]: How, if you can imagine, that I'm teaching you about the arcane arts, how can that come against you?
[SPEAKER_02]: How will you... What is the failing that will haunt you, given that your desire...
[SPEAKER_02]: If I fail.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Take that the next step further.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't want to fail.
[SPEAKER_02]: How's that gonna hurt you in the study of magic?
[SPEAKER_00]: Could kill me.
[SPEAKER_02]: And beyond just killing you?
[SPEAKER_00]: Evil.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if in your desire to be valuable, to prove yourself, you take on things that you cannot control before you can control them,
[SPEAKER_02]: You can fuck up an entire world of shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Point in case you decide to summon shit that you can't control, thinking that you can control it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Does that... do you get me?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So as long as you keep that in mind... Look, I desire to be a value.
[SPEAKER_02]: I desire power.
[SPEAKER_02]: But the thing is, is that if you're dead, your desires don't matter for shit because you're dead.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you have to be careful about overreaching, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: I've had to check myself many a time and sometimes I've overextended.
[SPEAKER_02]: When I start to teach you, there will come a time when I can no longer teach you and you're starting to teach yourself.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you have that inclination, because your mother helped you, to study.
[SPEAKER_02]: So as you study the arcane, there will come a time when you don't consult with me.
[SPEAKER_02]: And if you can't keep in mind that you can overreach, you'll overreach.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it may have much more dire consequences than just your own death.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you understand that?
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll see.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I'll teach him if he wants to become a first-level manager user.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'll teach you.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's gonna be some basic stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me see.
[SPEAKER_02]: Given your skills, how would you describe yourself, your current occupation?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is this a job application, bro?
[SPEAKER_00]: You bet it is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because you reflect on me.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you go out there and you look like an income pooper or an idiot, I'm going to have every assassin trying to take me out because they think I'm an income pooper and I'm an idiot.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if you're going to be my acolyte, initiate... What do you want to know?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, how do you see yourself?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, what's your specialty?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, is it just... Look.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gouge is great at direct confrontation.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't even know that he's a good poisoner.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, maybe he is, but... Yeah, I've seen him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just think that Gouge is great at intimidation and he's great at cutting throats.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know that he has any more subtlety than just intimidation and cutting throats.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I'm going to add to this.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gouge is not even a good fighter.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gouge is a great, dirty fighter.
[SPEAKER_02]: So what I'm saying is, what do you see as your strengths within the occupation?
[SPEAKER_02]: What are you really good at?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, disguise, when we were using- Disguise, yeah, sure, disguise.
[SPEAKER_00]: I see myself as, I don't see myself as direct confrontation.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that's subterfuge, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Subterfuge is disguise, it's misdirection.
[SPEAKER_02]: In the arcane arts that would also be- Unseen, being unseen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Illusionary.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So would I pick his initial spells from my spell list?
[SPEAKER_02]: You give him the spell list that you want.
[SPEAKER_02]: That I want.
[SPEAKER_02]: You give him to study six spells.
[SPEAKER_02]: How many of those are cantrips?
[SPEAKER_02]: He picks the cantrips.
[SPEAKER_02]: He gets to do that on his own?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or he picks them from my list?
[SPEAKER_01]: He has to pick two from you, and then you want him to develop his own.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you get to pick six spells that you give to him in your spell book from the first level.
[SPEAKER_01]: But if you don't have six spells, you should have six spells.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have like eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you can withhold all you want.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you might want to write this down.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just saying that to you as... Don't worry about it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: So do I give him any cantrips or does he actually just literally get to pick from the list of cantrips on his own?
[SPEAKER_02]: You give him two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Of cantrips?
[SPEAKER_01]: Of cantrips.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then he gets to pick what he wants.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think at the beginning, when you're first level, you get three cantrips.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so he'll get to pick one on his own.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, I'm gonna give you Mending and I'm gonna give you Light.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the reason why is because I think that
[SPEAKER_02]: From what you're telling me who you are, you need to progress.
[SPEAKER_02]: I progressed as a mage.
[SPEAKER_02]: So what that meant was that I needed to have things that I could kill people with from the very beginning.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can already kill people.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you need to think of the arcane arts as supplementing your ability to kill people.
[SPEAKER_02]: Mending?
[SPEAKER_02]: Can you give me one example of how mending could help you?
[SPEAKER_00]: Fixing some sort of machinery or equipment.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's weak.
[SPEAKER_02]: Come on.
[SPEAKER_02]: In your current occupation, as a rogue, fixing my grappling hook.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so fixing your own equipment.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: How about you break a window to enter into a place and you fix the window that you just broke?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I guess.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right, cover your tracks?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: And if I give you light...
[SPEAKER_00]: If you're going to ask me how to use light, that's pretty lame.
[SPEAKER_02]: Have you ever put light on somebody's full plate helmet?
[SPEAKER_00]: It blinds them.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So light is more than just light.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's only up to your imagination.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's light.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have...
[SPEAKER_00]: This is 18.
[SPEAKER_00]: Come here for a sec.
[SPEAKER_01]: You realize another use for mending, which is ducal seals, or letters, when they break the seal, you can read the note and seal it back and mend it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And no one knows that you've read the letter.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's minis.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if I give you as two cantrips, you can still select from your own and I can make sure that you get into the Archivist section of the Arcane Arts in the library.
[SPEAKER_02]: But if I give you Mending and I give you Light...
[SPEAKER_02]: Now these are his cantrips.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cantrips you can cast as many times as you want.
[SPEAKER_02]: You understand that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, but there's this, a cost that comes from your energy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Once you start casting anything of a certain intensity,
[SPEAKER_02]: As it graduates.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have limited usages.
[SPEAKER_02]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_00]: For these higher spells.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, for anything higher, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: So these aren't even what I would call entry-level spells.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cantrips are something that are like, ah, I mean, it's just like, it's like lighting a fire.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, you can light a fire from your fingertip, and then you've got a fire for your cannon.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if I do mending, I just ask you about that light.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you think that you can use those two?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or, I mean, I don't detect that he is like a demi-human that has dark vision, do I?
[SPEAKER_02]: He's human, even though you've never seen his face.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, I've never seen his face.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you have dark vision naturally?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, then light could be valuable to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Even if it was only to...
[SPEAKER_02]: Investigate an empty room to determine if you were trying to find hidden traps or hidden alcoves or places.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, you can cast as many times as you want.
[SPEAKER_02]: So those are the two things that I'll give you for cantrips.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll also teach you, how many, was it six first level spells?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, normally when a...
[SPEAKER_02]: I know you said I can kind of withhold if I wanted.
[SPEAKER_01]: ...initiate becomes a wizard.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the wizard that's teaching them gives them the six sort of spells.
[SPEAKER_01]: And one of the things about becoming a wizard is to transcribe those spells into their initial spellbook.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we'll get you a spellbook, and what you'll do is that I will allow you to transcribe.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now you'll have to practice, and you're going to fail at this.
[SPEAKER_02]: When you're first starting to write the arcane arts, it comes with a skill of its own.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you'll have to practice it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll observe.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you've miswritten any aspect of it, I'll let you know and you'll have to rewrite it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Does that make sense?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: What do you imagine in your current occupation, how could you use sleep?
[SPEAKER_00]: Instead of killing a guard that I want to sneak past, I could just cast sleep on him and drag him to a corner.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tell me, how would you use in your current occupation something like protection from good or evil?
[SPEAKER_00]: What does protection from good or evil do?
[SPEAKER_02]: That's a fair question.
[SPEAKER_02]: Moving on to the next.
[SPEAKER_02]: How about, do you ever run into any kind of magical traps?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Have you already?
[SPEAKER_02]: Have you?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you remember?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you have.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have actually.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think detect magic would help you even before you detect traps.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So because it'll help you identify what is a magical ward versus a mundane.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know what the word mundane means, correct?
[SPEAKER_00]: Physical.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Material world.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if I give you Detect Magic, if I give you Sleep, if I give you Protect from Good and Evil, it's just think of Protect, period.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't need a familiar.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, you got that homunculus thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: What do you use that for?
[SPEAKER_02]: I've never had one.
[SPEAKER_02]: How do you use it?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's kind of like I just...
[SPEAKER_00]: Look through its eyes, its own eyes, and you can shape it into other things.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like right now it's a lizard.
[SPEAKER_00]: I could shape it into a frickin' gopher if I wanted to.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it would behave like an organic gopher?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, well, I control it, so...
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean like, but it would have claws and be able to dig.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, or if, or like, so one of the things is... Can you change it into a bird?
[SPEAKER_02]: And can it fly?
[SPEAKER_00]: You might be able to, but I can't.
[SPEAKER_02]: So there are limitations on what you can change it into now.
[SPEAKER_00]: So right now it's made of clay, and what happens to clay if it gets wet?
[SPEAKER_00]: It dissolves.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I have special clay I have gotten myself.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can't just jump into the ocean and be a fish?
[SPEAKER_00]: I haven't tested that out yet, but it should be resistant to water.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you just asked me what happens to clay when it gets wet?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, that's how it normally is.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you grab clay just normally off...
[SPEAKER_02]: It just becomes a blob.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then your homunculi will dissipate him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Does it reappear at a different time of your choosing?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you have to make it.
[SPEAKER_00]: If it dies, it dies.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: And your chief benefit of having a homunculi is to be able to send it out and to see through... You've seen me use it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have, but I'm asking you specifically to describe its use.
[SPEAKER_00]: Scouting is probably the best.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, I mean you've seen me use my toad.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, your toad.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pretty lame.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just saying.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's limited.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can it scale the ceiling?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: It drew out the guards that we then took out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, well it wasn't as cool as my homoculi going up on the ceiling above him.
[SPEAKER_02]: A toad's a natural creature.
[SPEAKER_02]: In a castle?
[SPEAKER_02]: Your homunculi is gonna freak people out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure, in a castle, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, there's no toads walking around in castles.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm sorry, but a little clay gingerbread thing is gonna, like, you know, attract the wrong type of attention.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you think your toad's gonna attract the right kind of attention?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it obviously did.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where are toads from?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're in the middle of an ocean.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, water.
[SPEAKER_00]: In a castle.
[SPEAKER_00]: How many toads do you see hopping across the hallway?
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you think people don't drink fresh water?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, toads don't just hop through hallways.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sure they do.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, they don't.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're totally bullshitting me.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not bullshitting me.
[SPEAKER_00]: What kind of mage is this?
[SPEAKER_02]: Hush, that's the other thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: You have to do what I say.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh god, here we go.
[SPEAKER_02]: So protection from good from evil, sleep, detect magic.
[SPEAKER_02]: Have you ever wielded a weapon or an item, or jewelry included, that you've taken off of somebody that you probably shouldn't have put on?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or you shouldn't have wielded, meaning it had some kind of backlash to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, that would be identified.
[SPEAKER_02]: What about your face mask?
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what I'm thinking, but...
[SPEAKER_00]: The one you got?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, at the market.
[SPEAKER_02]: The one that I didn't like, that I responded to negatively?
[SPEAKER_02]: But he was able to take that off, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: I wouldn't necessarily suspect that.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not on right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right now I have my palace mask.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that the silver one?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like a formal and informal thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he had one that was like a black metal mask.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's the one you didn't like.
[SPEAKER_02]: Was that the Scarlet Brotherhood?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: But if I know that he took it off, I already challenged him on that, so it didn't seem like it was stuck.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's not saying that it's stuck.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you detected magic and there was none.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: The implication was... Just that somebody had sold it to him or that he had bought it for a reason that I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: The implication was being part of something.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe he didn't know, maybe he did.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who knows, but whatever the case.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like wearing a squasca.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, dude, what's wrong?
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you a Nazi?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or are you not a Nazi?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's like ingrained on my forehead.
[SPEAKER_02]: Did you accidentally?
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like a Gen Z kid with a squasca.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he's all like, come on, man.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's like an Indian peace symbol.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's the windows.
[SPEAKER_01]: I did the windows.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was a thousand years ago, but a hundred years ago it was something different.
[SPEAKER_02]: Quite a bit different.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I'm going to give you identify, and I'm going to just stop at that.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you've got sleep, you've got identify, you've got detect magic, you've got protection.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I'll give you Shield.
[SPEAKER_02]: Shield's a good one to learn.
[SPEAKER_02]: Shield is a reaction.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's the only spell that I can give you at this level that allows you, if you're about to get hit... To stop incoming projectiles.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, and what it'll do is it'll create a force that almost nothing can get through.
[SPEAKER_02]: There are some things that can get through it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now that's, I believe, five.
[SPEAKER_01]: So let me see what Shield does.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gives you a plus five to your AC, the entire round that you cast it, and if magic missile has been shot at you, it totally knocks that out.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the plus five AC is pretty cool, and it can be used generally.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it's only good for that one round.
[SPEAKER_02]: So now, the idea about casting spells, which I want you to understand, is that you only have, I've given you, which you're going to have to transmute, you know, you're going to have to translate and write into your own spell book.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I'm going to give you a spellbook, and you're going to screw it up, so I'm probably going to have you practice on just regular parchment, which it won't be the same thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not like making a scroll, but at least you can try to do a facsimile of that.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you're only allowed to kind of actually, your energy right now at your level is probably going to have two, maybe three.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is it four?
[SPEAKER_02]: Two?
[SPEAKER_02]: Two persons.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it's not that he can actually remember.
[SPEAKER_01]: When he becomes
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, the number of spells he's going to be able to memorize is his level as a wizard plus his intelligence.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that would be five.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're going to become a wizard if he teaches you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wizard and mages are the same thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sorcerers are different.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorcerers are garbage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Warlocks are like evil.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sorcerers and warlocks are even more than garbage.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, they are garbage!
[SPEAKER_00]: I was gonna say, what's the point to them?
[SPEAKER_00]: Cantrips.
[SPEAKER_02]: They sell part of their soul to an otherworldly force and worship its ass.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sorcerers are actually less garbage than warlocks, by the way.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because I know sorcerers have the weird thing where they cast spells.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ah, they call it natural magic.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not the same.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, like a random spell happens where they grow a third eye or something.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna teach you how to take the cosmic energy of all living things and use it.
[SPEAKER_02]: So at five spells, you'll have five opportunities.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now I want you to understand too, you can use a spell more than once.
[SPEAKER_02]: That you have memorized, but you can't use these spells more than five times total before you take a full rest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you understand that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: You gotta take a full rest to get your spell slots back.
[SPEAKER_02]: And how many do you have?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: With two spell slots, he can memorize five spells.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he can have five spells ready to go.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you can only cast two spells.
[SPEAKER_01]: So he has more knowledge than power.
[SPEAKER_02]: Does that make sense?
[SPEAKER_02]: As you go up, that will increase.
[SPEAKER_02]: And at some point, it's going to increase quite a bit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now if you start on this track, if he wants to do both, now I'm just talking to the DM, if he wants to do both, meaning let's say that he, is he obligated to get them like in those old rules where he has to go one for one?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so he could do first level, and then when he goes up a level, he could do fifth level.
[SPEAKER_02]: He can do whatever he wants as he goes up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, the thing is, is once you hit 4th level, to get to 5th level, you have to train for 20 days.
[SPEAKER_02]: And spend money.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that's what he's up against right now, because he's a 4th level rogue.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you a rogue assassin?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because you got to pick that up.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's a rogue assassin.
[SPEAKER_01]: And so if he wants to be a fifth level assassin, he's got to train for 20 days.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_01]: And so if he wants to go up, because he can go up a level, he can become a wizard, a first level wizard, today.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So this is a choice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you wish to go this way?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, Jude, what's the first thing you're going to try and teach him?
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, do you mean spell-wise?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, do you want to start with cantrip?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I'm an archivist.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to, like, start with writing shit down.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, yes, I will start with a cantrip, but I'm going to make them write it down.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, which cantrip?
[SPEAKER_02]: Mending.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think mending would probably be even more important to him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so Jude begins to instruct you in mending.
[SPEAKER_01]: A cantrip.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, this is a DC 15 roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's difficulty level 15.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: But Jude's intelligence bonus and your intelligence bonus apply to the roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what's your intelligence bonus?
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus four.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus five.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, it's a plus nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: You have to roll on a 20-sided die in the first hour.
[SPEAKER_01]: A 15 with a plus nine to the roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: So where's the 20-sided die?
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't roll below a four.
[SPEAKER_01]: You got it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, Jude begins to teach you mending.
[SPEAKER_01]: You want to break something?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you break?
[SPEAKER_01]: Chair.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude goes over and smashes the chair to pieces.
[SPEAKER_01]: Were you a baby in it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Were you suckled in this chair?
[SPEAKER_00]: Bro, this is my fucking palace.
[SPEAKER_02]: I sit in that chair, asshole.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, look, do you want me to break the vase?
[SPEAKER_00]: No!
[SPEAKER_00]: Mend it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't touch anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mend the chair.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, if I fucking fail, I'm reporting your ass.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what's happening.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't really care.
[SPEAKER_00]: My homocula, I saw it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't really care.
[SPEAKER_02]: 5 plus 9 is 14.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's a DC 15.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, he tries for an hour to mend it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, before he's even done with the hour as he's struggling...
[SPEAKER_01]: Hang on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me explain this.
[SPEAKER_01]: He is actually doing decently and the cracks...
[SPEAKER_01]: In the chair, come together, but then come apart.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he's got a problem with permanence.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, I'm still not impressed.
[SPEAKER_02]: So as he's doing the last stage, I tip over that bass.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then I'm all like, you're gonna have a lot of things that you're gonna have to mend.
[SPEAKER_00]: I suggest that you speed up.
[SPEAKER_00]: I hope you got a lot of money.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're gonna fix them.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're paying for it.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're gonna fix them like we're brand new.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, right now that chair's still broken.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, cuz you suck.
[SPEAKER_00]: And who broke it?
[SPEAKER_01]: You.
[SPEAKER_02]: Get to working.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, next hour.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ten.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so... Underdude's tutelage... Keep the mic flat, man.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You actually fixed the chair.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're somewhat impressed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two hours.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pretty good.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: And?
[SPEAKER_01]: Get on the base.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just did the base.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, it's a DC-10 thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, you did the chair.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a DC-10.
[SPEAKER_01]: This will solidify your cantrip.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or not, and I'll break something up.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's your money, either way, I don't care.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, that's good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, because you got a plus nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you learn mending.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, here's the deal.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can stop here.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't have to be a wizard, but if you go forward,
[SPEAKER_01]: He'll be an assassin that knows how to cast Mindy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nah, I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're at the gate.
[SPEAKER_02]: Also, you gotta think about me.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not a fun teacher.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was gonna actually ask, how long do I have to, do I have to have him as a teacher?
[SPEAKER_02]: Pretty much.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you see another wizard around?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can always complain to daddy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I think I will.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, you don't have a daddy.
[SPEAKER_02]: You better shut up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, you don't have a daddy.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't know this.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can go complain to mommy.
[SPEAKER_01]: She's dead.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, you don't have a mommy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, let me think about it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Stop telling him stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's gonna make sub-hints now for the next AT&D session.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, well, maybe you should tell your dad.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uncle.
[SPEAKER_00]: Your uncle.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll be like, oh, your uncle hired me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Go ahead.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's next?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, I'm gonna take him to the dark part of the dungeon, and we're gonna learn light.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you guys walk down to the dungeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where you had previously interrogated that guy, the thief.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me just let one of the guardsmen know.
[SPEAKER_02]: We need a room for practice, aren't we?
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you basically are saying, now let's teach you light.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you want him to transcribe this into what will be his spellbook.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you spend 30 minutes trying to find something that's an appropriate spell bug.
[SPEAKER_01]: You basically give him a piece of capris for the cost of one gold coin.
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a spell.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is...
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm teaching you how it goes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Take a handful of money and throw it at him.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're so dramatic.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is gonna come against you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Bitch.
[SPEAKER_01]: You pick up one coin?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, just whatever it always cost me for the packers.
[SPEAKER_01]: One coin?
[SPEAKER_01]: And you go down to the basement with a candle and you begin talking to him about how to transcribe the spell.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: First level spell.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, it's still a cantrip.
[SPEAKER_02]: Should I actually switch?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, it's light.
[SPEAKER_01]: Light.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude's practicing.
[SPEAKER_01]: No transcribing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so he's talking to you about invocations.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: DC-15, roll.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you don't make it, I'm hucking a chair at you.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's no chairs down here.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're chains.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're chains of the wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: What is that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Four.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's a thirteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thirteen.
[SPEAKER_00]: I huck it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I huck something out of his knees.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: A bowl?
[SPEAKER_02]: Something, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Roll.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're all yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Get your own gun.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do I get advantage?
[SPEAKER_00]: Nope, you got three, bro.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I suck it.
[SPEAKER_00]: You did worse than me.
[SPEAKER_00]: It totally misses you.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it clings against the wall, and you know I threw something at you.
[SPEAKER_00]: You may have magic, but I can throw and stab shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: You may have magic?
[SPEAKER_02]: I cast a light right between his eyebrows.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah!
[SPEAKER_00]: Light on your eyebrows.
[SPEAKER_00]: You can't see my eyebrows because I have a mask on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, right here between on your mask.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pass light on your mask.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I have this bracelet on the edge of my island.
[SPEAKER_00]: You become blinded.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Stand there and... You stand there giving the finger.
[SPEAKER_02]: I go over and I grab the bowl and I bash him in the leg.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like in a shin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You done?
[SPEAKER_00]: Being a baby?
[SPEAKER_00]: Man up, bro.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm like 22, and how old are you, bro?
[SPEAKER_00]: You're an old fart maid, bro.
[SPEAKER_00]: Come on.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm pretty old in human years.
[SPEAKER_02]: Go ahead.
[SPEAKER_02]: I dispel it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: You done?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna hit you again.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you can't get it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Call the guards.
[SPEAKER_02]: Mommy?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Aw, she's dead.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, I'm gonna use that one.
[SPEAKER_00]: It doesn't matter.
[SPEAKER_00]: Still got power here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Come on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Five plus nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fourteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll bash him in the knee.
[SPEAKER_00]: I cast life first so that I don't...
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna slit your achilles if you do that one more time.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, you're gonna wanna kill me a bunch of times before this is over, but what this will prove is that when the shit is down and you've got somebody in full plate mail, trust me, I've had this happen, that's trying to, like, decapitate you, you're gonna have it down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fair enough.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, the third hour goes.
[SPEAKER_01]: He tries to learn light.
[SPEAKER_01]: Again.
[SPEAKER_01]: God, what the?
[SPEAKER_01]: All right, so.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's paint.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, by the way, it's 7pm.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to keep going?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to give him one more hour.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because only good shit happens in the dark.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we've got like, still a little bit of twilight.
[SPEAKER_02]: What season is it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Is it summer?
[SPEAKER_02]: Stay light until late?
[SPEAKER_01]: It is actually spring.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so 8 o'clock.
[SPEAKER_02]: We can go one more hour.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's actually early summer, late spring.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've bruised his knees at least one on each side.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not fucking around with you.
[SPEAKER_02]: You could have stopped.
[SPEAKER_02]: Would you still like to stop, since you can't seem to master light?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna weld a mask to your face.
[SPEAKER_02]: You gotta be able to beat me up first.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's not very hard.
[SPEAKER_00]: God, bro.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where do we get these people, bro?
[SPEAKER_00]: How desperate are we hurting for money?
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll it.
[SPEAKER_00]: First gouge, then... What the fuck?
[SPEAKER_00]: What is that?
[SPEAKER_00]: God, dude, it's a four.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hold on.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's tired.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't bash him.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just take him out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's go.
[SPEAKER_02]: Come on.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a good first day.
[SPEAKER_02]: You got a cantrip.
[SPEAKER_02]: You got it easy.
[SPEAKER_02]: The first cantrip.
[SPEAKER_02]: Second one, don't worry about it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I got bashed a lot.
[SPEAKER_02]: Stop taking it personal.
[SPEAKER_02]: Come on, keep some of that objectivity.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know that passionate part of you that wanted to kill every single Toli on the, you know, Geralee Bay?
[SPEAKER_02]: Geralee Bay?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see, you forgot.
[SPEAKER_02]: You forgot that you kind of freaked out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, I remember I...
[SPEAKER_00]: Hang on.